sir how are you doing
good it's good to see you again have you
been
uh everything is going great when i get
to talk to you oh that's
very kind i mean that so sincerely we've
had some good interviews in the past i
thought
yeah listen it's hitting me right now
that you realize who i am
and that to me is [ __ ] crazy so
i'm just throwing that out there as a
huge fan of your work um so let me jump
in and say pig is fantastic
and you are so great in this role i'm
curious
um what was it about this project that
said i i want to do this this is
important to me
it was a screenplay
that i thought was written
with great sincerity uh
it had no other motivation
than to just tell a quiet story
of loss there were things about it that
reminded me of
a like almost like a japanese haiku
in meaning that you know five seven five
syllables that
what was said between the syllables
was as important or more important than
the words themselves
that it was a very evocative screenplay
and michael was a director who wanted to
tell a different kind of
story it was a meditation of sorts on
loss
and i was at a point in my own life
where it was kind of like no acting
please
i um i have
close relationships with my animals
brothers and sisters my cats my dogs
and um you know i would sometimes get
bad dreams
about losing my cat you know we've all
become very close to
our our animals after what we've been
through with the pandemic and quarantine
and um so i i didn't feel like it would
be
a huge challenge to to play this role
that it would come out
just very easily because i felt i had
the
relationships and the life experience to
tell the story
so that's what drew me to it i love
learning about the behind the scenes
of the making of a movie is there
anything that you think might surprise
people to learn about the making of pig
i don't know about surprise uh per se
i but i do think that a a tremendous
amount of
thought went into
conveying the joy of
of making a a
a dish a culinary an epicurean
experience
that can communicate
uh emotion and i had two excellent chefs
to work with uh chef chris of chef
ruckner from le pigeon and
they spent some time with me i'm very
passionate about food it's what i'm
interested in
food for me always came first then
music then uh film performance but
food to me is it's uh it's something i
have great respect for
and the regard for food all spiritual
level
of uh the the the power
of food um and i think that came through
especially in the filmmaking process
that michael had great regard
he had me read marco pierre white uh
devil in the kitchen and that was very
effective so a lot of thought went into
the food itself and how it would be
presented
i have to tell you that um one of my
most anticipated films
in the upcoming future is something with
you the unbearable weight of massive
talent
i could not be more excited for that
film if i could see it tomorrow i would
pay money
um what can you say about that project
because it sounds
awesome well i think what i can say
about the project
is that everybody involved uh tom gorman
kevin eden uh pedro pascal
everybody came into it with genuine
passion and care
uh that the movie was was nobody
uh pulled their punches or
or tried to uh sweep anything under the
rug
everything was approached with
tremendous
care um having said that
i i will probably never see the movie
myself
because the idea of going meta and
playing
a quote-unquote surrealistic version of
myself
and a quote-unquote surrealistic version
or interpretation of
a younger version of myself going
head-to-head it might just be
too psychologically uh
invasive for one nicolas cage
i i i but i i can tell you that it
came from the right place from all of us
and it and it has a lot of heart
and and the movie means well i know that
much
i heard the script was awesome it's a
great script and
and and it created quite a uh quite a
bit of uh
bidding business war that part i don't
get involved in but
but it did it did it was very evocative
for whatever reason that i can't explain
uh
it's inexplicable to me but nonetheless
it is
what it is and it happened so i
i will have to hear from you what you
think of it um
and uh i will go to the premiere but i'm
probably not going to be sitting in the
audience
i completely get it i mean this
sincerely pig is fantastic
and i really hope people um come out to
see it because you're working it
is so good thank you very much and happy
to speak with you again
um listen have a fantastic day thank you
so much for your time
thank you